WELCOME BACK.
ALONGSIDE IMMIGRATION, DONALD
TRUMPS PROMISED TO FIX THE
ECONOMY AND DO IT IN A WAY
THAT HELPS WORKING AMERICANS,
NOT JUST THE RICH WAS THE
REASON HE WAS ELECTED.
LOOK AT THE CONTRAST BETWEEN
WALL STREET AND THE REAL
ECONOMY.
IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS THE
STOCK MARKET TANKED OVER FEARS
THE ECONOMY WAS HEADED IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION BUT IN THE
REAL WORLD THE AMERICAN
CONSUMER POWERED HEAD.
HOLIDAY SALES HIT THEIR
HIGHEST MARK IN SIX YEARS.
WALL STREET PRAISE THE
PRESIDENT'S POLICY BECAUSE IT
MAKES IT HARDER.
[INAUDIBLE]
BUT IN THE REAL WORLD THEY ARE
HELPING EXACTLY THE PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT DONALD TRUMP
PROMISED.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT GAP BETWEEN
SKILLED AND UNSKILLED WORKERS
ARE SHRINKING AND WAGES ARE
RISING AND COMPANIES ARE
FORCED TO HIRE WORKERS THEY
MAY HAVE OVERLOOKED IN THE
PAST.
THAT'S WHAT I CALL POSITIVE
POPULISM.
HERE WE ARE, I WANT TO START
WITH YOU.
WHAT'S THE CHANCES THAT THE
BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS, THE
DEMOCRATS WHO KIND OF WENT TO
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE THEY
WANTED THIS KIND OF POLICY, IT
SEEMS LIKE THEY'VE DRIFTED
AWAY A BIT.
WE SAW THAT A LITTLE BIT IN
2018.
DO YOU THINK THEIR SUCCESS
WILL BRING THEM BACK TO THE
PRESIDENT CAMP IN THE YEARS
AHEAD.
>> THAT WAS SUCH A GREAT
POINT.
I'M SO APPRECIATIVE FOR IT.
THAT'S FOR THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
REALLY FAILS.
THEY FAILED TO TALK ABOUT
BUSINESS OWNERS.
THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WALL STREET AND ME
BEING A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER.
A SMALL DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HOW
WHAT I WAS ABLE TO EMPLOY AND
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE ONE SO FAR
LEFT THAT EVERYTHING IS ABOUT
THE EVIL, EVIL WALL STREET
WHERE THEY THOUGHT FORGOTTEN
ABOUT THE AVERAGE WORKING
PERSON.
EVEN START
EVEN STORT
EVEN STOCK MARKET HAS
TANKED BUT THE ECONOMY HAS
DONE WELL, I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT.
THIS WILL EVENTUALLY MOVE
PEOPLE CLOSER TO TRUMP INSTEAD
OF TALKING ABOUT BUSINESS, AND
SOME AFFLICTED PARALYZE TO
TALK ABOUT IT BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
SOCIAL ISSUES I ALSO
AN ECONOMIC ENGINE THAT
DOESN'T SOLVE OUR SOCIAL
PROBLEMS OF BUGS SURE MAKES IT
EASIER AND THAT'S WERE
DEMOCRATS FAIL.
YOU'LL SEE A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN YOUR MODERATES AND
THOSE IN THE MIDDLE AND THOSE
WHO ARE PROGRESSIVE THAT ARE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IN
2020.
>> IF YOU JUST LOOK AT WALL
STREET YOU THINK EVERYTHING'S
FALLING APART, BUT ALL THE
TIME COMMUTE JUST HAD GOOD
NEWS FOR THE AMERICAN WORKER.
>> IT'S BEEN GREAT NEWS FOR
THE AMERICAN WORKER AND WILL
GET BETTER.
WE'VE GOT THAT BIG INCREASE IN
MANUFACTURING JOBS TALKED
ABOUT IN THE REIT NEGOTIATED
NAFTA DOESN'T TAKE EFFECT FOR
COUPLE YEARS.
IT WILL PUSH MORE AUTO
MANUFACTURING IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THE DEAL THAT WILL GET CUT
WITH CHINA THIS YEAR, THERE
WILL BE A DEAL.
WILL PUSH MORE MANUFACTURING
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES.
ONCE WE CUT DOWN ON IMMIGRANTS
WHO ARE TAKING AMERICAN JOBS,
OVER 5 MILLION PEOPLE NOT
LEGALLY HERE IN THE COUNTRY
WHO ARE WORKING IN AMERICA,
THAT WILL CREATE MORE DEMAND
FOR THE MARGINAL UNSKILLED
WORKER AND PUSH WAGES UP EVEN
MORE AND IT WILL BE WONDERFUL
NEWS FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP GOING
AND 2020.
>> THAT'S VERY OPTIMISTIC BUT
SOMETIMES I THINK THE WALL
STREET NEGATIVITY CAN INFECT
THE REAL ECONOMY.
>> POTENTIALLY BUT ALSO THE
COVERAGE OF THE WHITE HOUSE OF
WALL STREET.
I THINK OF THE MEDIA FOCUSES
ON VOLATILITY THEN I THINK
THAT WILL TRANSLATE IN THE
MARKET, PERSONALLY.
THE REASON WHY I THINK WITH
THE BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS OF
2018 THAT IT DOESN'T DO QUITE
AS WELL AS BECAUSE PRESIDENT
TRUMP WASN'T ON THE BALLOT AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP PASSED THROUGH
THE VICTORY THROUGH THE WHITE
HOUSE, ALWAYS THE RUST BELT
AND AGAIN IN 2020 IT WILL BE
THROUGH THE RUST BELT.
I THINK WHY PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS SO REFRESHING TO A LOT OF
THESE BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS IS
ONE YOU HAD PRESIDENT OBAMA
WHO PURSUED A POLICY OF
IDENTITY POLITICS AND FORGOT
ABOUT THE REST OF AMERICA AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP SPOKE TO THE
PEOPLE.
YOU ALSO HAVE AN ISSUE LIKE
COAL, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
WAGING A WAR ON COAL.
HILLARY CLINTON SAID SHE
WANTED TO PUT COAL WORKERS OUT
OF BUSINESS IN HERE YOU HAVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP COMING IN AND
SAYING I CARE ABOUT YOU, I
KNOW YOU'RE HURTING AND I WANT
JOBS TO COME BACK TO YOUR
COMMUNITIES SO IMAGINE HOW
REFRESHING THAT HAS TO SOUND
TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND
CLEARLY HE'S FALLING THROUGH
FOLLOWING THROUGH.
>> GREAT.